let me ask you a difficult question
about the darker side of human nature of
human power
of institutions
what's your view on the long history and
widespread reports of sexual abuse of
children
by a catholic priest so this is a a
difficult topic but maybe an important
one to shine a light on yeah it's awful
you know and it's it's been a problem go
back to peter damien back in the 11th
century was talking about it so it's
been a problem and whenever really
sinful human beings have been in close
proximity to children we've we find this
issue has it been around the church yes
um
has it surfaced in a kind of sickening
way in the last 30 years absolutely
um
i'm glad the church has made important
strides and it has
back in 2002 there was a thing called
the dallas accords where the bishops of
america put a lot of these protocols in
place that really have been effective
at ameliorating this problem
the numbers spiked in the 70s and 80s
and that's been demonstrated over and
over again and then they fell
dramatically after that so
that's not to excuse anything but to say
i think progress has been made with it
what's the impulse to secrecy
yeah well to protect institutions you
know that's always that's a sinful uh
instinct uh i'm not all together i mean
sure an institution is worth protecting
but if it reaches the point where you're
indifferent to people's uh
well-being then you're in trouble
so institutions role
should be transparent and honest with
the sins of its members and itself
sure yeah
so maybe you can speak to the fact
uh as a priest the bishop
as part of catholicism
you're not allowed to marry
you're not allowed to have sex
uh you're you're sworn to celibacy
what is what is behind that idea
what is the sort of we talked about some
broad stroke yeah
ideas of love you know what's behind the
idea of celibacy and that's a good way
to get at it it's a path of love so it
the church is always in favor of
inculcating love marriage is a path of
love but so is celibacy
um saint paul talks about someone who is
preoccupied with the things of of this
world and family and those who are free
from that are freer for doing the the
work of god so that's kind of a
pragmatic justification for celibacy and
we still i think take that seriously
look at my own life i mean celibacy has
enabled me to do all kinds of things and
go places and and
and
minister in a way that i could not if i
had been married so i get it i get the
pragmatic side but i i'm more interested
in the sort of mystical side of it um
remember jesus was challenged about the
person who had a whole series of of uh
husbands and and then they all died and
so in heaven which one will uh you know
which which husband will the wife have
and his answer is in heaven people don't
marry and they're not given in marriage
there's a there's a higher way of love
it's a more radical way of love it's not
tied to a particular but i think through
god is tied to everybody
the celibate and this has been to the
beginning of the church
not as a law but there were there were
celibates from the very beginning of the
church including jesus of course and
paul
um
they sensed something that that way of
living
mystically anticipates the way we'll
love in heaven
it's a sign even now
within this world of how we will all
love in heaven
so
in that way it's a bit like pacifists um
i'm glad there are pacifists in the
church and i i've known some you know
some very powerful witnesses to pacifism
i'm glad they're pacifists because they
witness even now to how we will be in
heaven when every tear is wiped away and
we beat our swords into plowshares and
you know
heaven's a place of radical peace
that some people even now live it
at the same time i'm glad not everyone's
a pacifist because i i would hold with
the church to just war theory that
there's sometimes all we can do in this
finite world is to is to fight you know
uh manifest wickedness
so and just in the same way there's just
sex
well no right i'm glad there are
celibates but i'm glad not everyone's a
celebrity i wouldn't want that i mean
because because uh married love is a
marvelous expression of the divine love
so that's why it's good there are some
and it's always been a small number the
actual experience of it would you
uh the spiritual nature of it is it
similar to fasting so i've been enjoying
fasting uh recently so not eating yeah
uh for several days that kind of stuff
and that somehow brings you
even deeper i'm in general in love with
everything in nate with nature and
everything i see the beauty in the world
but there's a greater intensity to that
when you're fasting for example
yeah i i might use the language of you
know sublimation or redirection of
energy and all that um
i i think that's true there's a certain
sublimation of energies into
um
prayer into
mysticism into ministry
um a redirection of energies
so it's meant to be life enhancing the
same way fasting is is meant ultimately
to be life enhancing and make you
healthier and happier
so celibacy is a is a path of love and i
think it does involve you a certain
redirection of energies i'd say that
don't you think
do you think
it's a heavy burden
for some humans to bear
some priest to bear is that sure is that
the thing given this the
the the sexual abuse scandal
um
is that the thing that breaks
no i i wouldn't tie that to celibacy and
that's been uh demonstrated over and
over again there's a priest named andrew
greeley who was a priest from my home
diocese of chicago and
andy did a lot of research he was
sociologist of religion did a lot of
research into that very question and
there really is not a correlation
between celibacy per se
and the sexual abuse of children or
anybody so i wouldn't make that
correlation so bad people sinful people
are going to do what they're going to do
i think people
who have a tendency toward
abusing children sexually are drawn to
situations where they get ready access
to kids and they get institutional cover
so that's something that you go through
the list of you know from sports and and
boy scouts etc um and that's been proven
again and again so i would tie it more
to that i wouldn't tie it to celibacy
you